what's he doing I have a list hey
youtubers welcome to part 1 of my many
part preview for season 4 Game of
Thrones that's right you thought it was
over for the season but I'm doing videos
all year long so get excited
today's a preview of King's Landing and
what's going on with all the main
characters that are there so a quick
recap of all the big moments from season
3 in King's Landing Tyrion Sansa wedding
Joffrey Margaery wedding getting ready
to happen seriously and Loras wedding
and Tywin and the Queen of thorns
plotting behind the scenes the Tyrells
are a big part of the story in season 4
so get ready if you remember from the
last couple of seasons the producers
have actually used the season premieres
in the season finale so just really
bookend a lot of the ohshit episodes so
the season premiere is just gonna pick
up right at the end of the season finale
that means in King's Landing
they'll just begin preparations for the
purple wedding that's Joffrey's wedding
to Margaery but we'll certainly be
getting married to Loras spoiler alert
she will not there's actually a big
conflict that they didn't really include
in the King's Landing scenes where the
Iron Islands are in conflict with King's
Landing I don't think they're gonna
include a lot of that in season 4 but
you did get to see your Ramsay snow male
Theon's I wonder what kind of postage he
had to pay on that there's thing I'm
sorry about that Theon reek it runs with
freaky so in my mind the real star of
King's Landing in season 4 is actually
gonna be Tyrion not only because he has
a lot of the ocean moments but because
the actor Peter Dinklage has actually
got proportionally more lines and more
scenes as the show has gone on he is one
of the main cast members but I feel like
fans have really gravitated towards him
just because he's so amazing he's
basically on life support now in season
4 he actually gets a blame for a really
really big thing that happens at the
purple wedding I don't want to explain
exactly what it is just because it's
such an awesome spoiler I'd like for you
guys to figure it out on your own but
let's just say he gets thrown in the
black cells it's serious and it's
all part of that big Joffrey slap moment
and that ties back to the Queen of
thorns we haven't seen her a lot on the
show just because Diana Rigg is only a
guest star but she plays a key role in
the purple wedding and the oh
moment I think that's actually gonna
come before episode 9 so I don't think
you'll have to wait too long to get that
that also leaves episode 9 open for an
even bigger ocean moment it's hard to
predict how the show is gonna play up
that season 9 Oh
moment but let's just say there's
actually several throughout the season
so it could be any one of them I'll be
talking more about them in my other
preview videos - and what about Sansa
don't we all just feel so horrible for
she's so sweet she's such an awesome
character if you remember pedobear
Littlefinger has actually been creepin
on her for the last couple of seasons
she actually accepts one of his offers
for escape and that leads to a really
interesting place but a lot of those
really awesome scenes don't happen till
the next book so I don't think a lot of
them will make it into season 4 so I
won't talk about them too much right now
let's just say her character continues
to get more and more interesting he was
actually one of my favorite characters
in the show for most of this season
let's talk about Jaime and Brienne they
made it back to King's Landing
relatively safely and a lot of season 4
will be Jaime react LeMay ting to life
in the capital and dealing with his hand
problem let's just say his new nickname
is going to be Jaime the golden hand
I'll let you guess on why that is
spoiler alert what's really interesting
about his character now at season 4 is
that he's basically a good guy they just
kind of implied that when he rescued
Brienne from the bear fight but if you
remember series character is actually
kind of frozen still in that state of
character development she's been in for
the last couple of seasons so it's gonna
be really interesting to see how Jaime
doesn't like to do the Sister Wives
anymore and Susie isn't really having
any of that so there's a lot of friction
between those two characters now in
season 4 that I think is gonna be really
cool so my next season for preview video
will post on Thursday be sure to
subscribe to get it
it'll cover the characters at the wall
like Jon Snow you grit the wildlings and
the White Walkers I'll also be posting a
preview of The Hobbit part 2 desolation
of Smaug especially with a lot of
Benedict Cumberbatch he's actually the
voice of Smaug that will happen on
Tuesday be sure to check back for that
in the meantime you can click here to
relive some of the big ocean moments
from the last couple of episodes and you
can click here to get that Hobbit video
I looked at the annotation as soon as I
post it in the meantime you can actually
watch more on Sherlock season 3
Benedict Cumberbatch for the win and
don't worry the north will always
remember Hyde's